>> Thanks.
I want to answer the question about whether
the rich countries are
doing enough to help the poorest countries.
First off, I believe that even in this global
downturn and deep
recession, that we've had in the UK, a huge
problem with our budget
deficit, we should protect what we spend on
overseas aid.
And the target we have for .7 percent of GDP,
and we should keep that.
Britain is a compassionate, generous nation
as we showing in terming of
the giving to Haiti.
We should continue with that.
But why is it that we haven't done better
in Haiti?
It's amazing some of the things that are being
done.
The pictures we see of children being pulled
from the rubble has made
us proud of what our emergency services are
able to do there.
And I do think the UN and individual countries
as well need to think
more about how we can have a standing ready-to-go
emergency force so
that we make sure that in the vital, golden,
first few hours after an
earthquake or another natural disaster we
save as many lives as
possible.
I raised this in the House of Commons with
the Prime Minister Gordon
Brown.
I think there's more we can do both in the
UK and internationally.
And I think that should be a real priority
as we start to learn the
lesson of how we can do even better when the
next Haiti strikes.